when we left off in the last video we
just completed the top portion of this
chart which is allowing us to consider
sn1 sn2 e1 and e2 mechanisms given a
particular substrate structure now we're
ready to add allylic and benzylic
substrates to our table before we add
allylic substrates I'd like to go into
their chemistry in a bit more detail
let's use a biological example this
compound dimethylallyl pyrophosphate is
a precursor to steroids in biochemical
pathways this pyrophosphate group are
the two phosphates linked together can
be thought of as X just a good leaving
group it's widely accepted that this
pyrophosphate group leaves on its own
and in this sn1 reaction forms a primary
allylic carbo cation this is possible
because there's extra stabilization in
this molecule we can draw a resonance
form that shows a tertiary carbo cation
contributing to this structure this
extra stabilization promotes the
ionization by sn1 however the side
containing the tertiary carbo cation
shown with this resonance form is
significantly sterically hindered
therefore nucleophiles end up adding to
this carbon atom to give products like
this I think this example does a pretty
good job of highlighting some of the
subtleties here we might not think about
this as ionizing to form a primary
allylic carbo cation but when we examine
the resonance we can see there are other
factors going on that makes the
ionization favorable so allylic
substrates
even when primary but usually under
special circumstances have the sn1
mechanism available to them so if you're
given a primary allylic substrate with
oh poor nucleophile under these polar
protic conditions I would think that
your instructor was kind of leaning you
toward an
and one situation especially if we have
some branching here we'll have resonance
stabilization as we've shown and so the
major mechanism for the poor
nucleophiles is going to be sn1 now e 1
is not a possible mechanism we can't
deprotonate the sp2 carbon atom here
we'd need a branch coming in this
direction to have any elimination
whatsoever and so sn1 is going to be the
only mechanism here weak bases strong
bases and strong hindered bases are
going to tip this toward an sn2
mechanism again since elimination can
occur with this substrate will predict
sn2 across the board next we need to
consider primary benzylic substrates ok
back to another little aside before I
add benzylic substrates to our table I
want to go into a little bit more about
them as well benzylic substrates have
electronic effects that can extend from
substituents that are on the ring all
the way over to the leaving group to
determine whether we'll see an sn1 or
sn2 mechanism let's look at an example
here we have a para methoxy substituted
benzyl chloride let's imagine treating
this with NASM e in our chart we saw
that weak nucleophiles with primary
substrates tend to go sn2 but this
reaction does not the methoxy group can
donate electrons into the ring pushing
out the leaving group and promoting an
sn1 mechanism let's draw our lone pairs
of electrons on oxygen and now we can
show resonance through the whole benzene
ring pushing out our leaving group in an
sn1 fashion this gives this intermediate
which can then be attacked by our
nucleophile giving our substitution
product so we can say that electron
donating substituents particularly those
para to the benzyl group will promote
sn1 reactions now by contrast para
electron withdrawing groups will promote
the sn2 mechanism under the same
conditions with the same nucleophile
let's look at why well
use a similar substrate just swapping
the methoxy for a nitro group
now this nitro group is pulling
electrons from the ring both inductively
because of this positive charge on the
nitrogen and we can show a resonance
form that just shows how profound the
resonance effect of this electron
withdrawing group is if we push our
electrons like this we'll get a
resonance form that shows that we have
carbo cation character a little bit of
Delta positive character here at this
carbon atom now imagine trying to make
this chlorine leave on its own we have
all this positive character here we're
trying to make a carbo cation here
that's gonna be really high energy so
substrates with this para electron
withdrawing group tend to favor the sn2
mechanism even though they're giving a
similar product so coming back to our
chart again with primary benzylic we
don't have the option of elimination we
need to eliminate from a carbon coming
off of here and that is not present so
I'd say this follows a similar pattern
to the allylic substrate so we're not
gonna add anything here this will just
be for the two of these however remember
we did see a case where even with a weak
base
we had an sn1 mechanism because of ring
electronics so let's just make a little
note so we should consider our ring
electronics because that weighs into the
substrate structure as the most
important factor in determining this but
for a simple unsubstituted case I would
predict this reactivity pattern next we
need to consider secondary allylic and
potentially tertiary which I'm showing
with this maybe little dashed line here
and let's consider the secondary and
tertiary benzylic with this case as well
now we have extra stabilization of a
carbo cation that would form here from
the extra substituents when treated with
a poor nucleophile I would predict again
sn1 but we have to acknowledge that II
one can compete here as well
now again with our strong bases and
strong hindered bases we have the
option for e2 elimination again because
we have these groups coming off here I
would predict under these conditions e
two mechanisms for both secondary and
tertiary now for our tertiary benzyl and
al L substrates again we can't have
backside attack so under these weekly
basic conditions we're going to predict
sn1 and e1 mechanisms to compete and I
think this is the hardest spot to fill
in on the chart I think under these
conditions it's really hard to know we'd
have to look for electronic effects
extra stabilization from groups being on
our al L and way all of that but here I
think this is the die seus part of our
table and that sn1 e1 and sn2 mechanisms
are all possible and we'll have to
consider those other points that we
learned so I hope this chart helped you
glean some information about the
reactivity patterns the top part in
particular has a very distinct pattern
that we can see from the colors and I
hope this video helped you come to grips
a little bit with all the subtleties and
the allylic and benzylic substrates that
makes these just more complicated
examples I hope you learned something if
you did please like and subscribe